what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we are here to watch the
official trailer or trailer dose for the
Marvels John how are you I am marvelous
Gregory how are you oh my God that is
good anyway guys listen up John and Greg
are going to be heading out to Comic-Con
tomorrow because we have a panel at
Comic Con Saturday at one o'clock P.M so
if you are there please go attend our
panel love to say hi to you secondly we
obviously have had merch with a Zero
edition that partnership is coming to an
end at the end of this month and here's
a shirt called a soda that we were going
to launch in August but because the
partnership is coming to an end now we
only have it available literally for
just like 10 days when I say limited
time I mean it after July 31st it's not
going to be selling anymore at all so if
you guys want to get yourself in a soda
shirt please go ahead and do it I got
one coming in the mail right now I'm
excited to wear it when the Ahsoka
series comes out anywho guys let's watch
this Marvel's trailer and see what it's
all about
yeah
Danvers prodigal child of the Milky Way
Nick Fury my favorite one-eyed man of
Entry how goes it out there
no air
space
right
nice Marvel logo be annihilator
and now I'm returning the favor
okay oh she got the bangle yeah
they're linked
so we switch places whenever we use them
Theory you can absorb light
I can see it and Kamala who's Kamala hi
she can turn light into physical matter
which I have never heard of I could
totally show you
oh my
sweet whoa
[Music]
everything and everyone
oh serving every planet we call home
Thor Ragnarok walks here I would never
choose to bring anybody into this
you are not the only thing standing
between this and the universe
pre-war rages on slurkin crossovers
yourself
higher higher for the faster further
faster baby
[Music]
I can't can you I got it
[Laughter]
that made me cooler I should have you
take that eye much sooner well that was
a fun trailer sure didn't really feel
like I got too much new from it but I
did get a better sense of where Carol
Danvers is at in particular what her Arc
might be it seems like that this is
going to be the kind of thing where she
she is like I gotta go Rogue I gotta do
this on my own this is something I can
handle the kind of the impression I'm
getting is that she's been handling a
lot of stuff by herself for such a long
time that she probably feels like she
can handle this on her own and it's
interesting going off of secret Invasion
where they had Nick Fury with this
certain Mission and he's like this is
personal this is something I cause now
you you're bringing him here and Carol
Danvers also kind of a similar thing
like personal Vendetta between her and
the uh what's it called the Korea
accusers
what she's rumored to be playing at
least and so I I like that personal
entanglement
so I like that personal entanglement and
then of course having to work through
with Monica of you know whatever
forgiveness that she has to go through
so there's some good Arc set up there
where you probably have Kamala as
more lore and fun I mean she still looks
like the best part of the trailers to me
she's still my favorite part uh from
everything we got weirdly even though I
didn't feel like I got much new in terms
of plot I still thought it was actually
a better trailer I would absolutely
agree this felt way more smooth and I
mean certainly they clearly communicate
a couple things about the strangeness of
what's happening to them and yeah them
all zapping into the You Know Places
each other was at the point they used
their powers but yeah this just felt a
lot more fleshed out and full and the
like quirky fun bits felt proportional
to the bits that were supposed to be
more like War heavy you know seeing
stuff that does hearken to like the
craze grow war that wages on despite
this peace treaty with the the
zandarians or whatever you're not
getting a giant glance at like the
climactic scenes I don't get the sense
except for this one big splash page
fight at the end of the trailer
certainly where they're all sort of
fighting in unison but you do get more
of like the intensity of the threat of
the villain whereas the first teaser
just kind of gave me like some cookies
happening to the the Marvels right now
one thing that I'm really excited for
too when I see all this imagery we're
getting Monica Rambo and of course we're
gonna get Kamala Khan who we saw in a
television series and now while you know
Disney plus they often throw so much
money at their television shows
simultaneously it's still a television
show it wouldn't be the same kind of
budget or focus of what you would put
towards the visual effects and realizing
their powers coming to fruition in a
cinematic type of experience right I'm
really excited for working out kind of
like when you watch like the Power
Rangers show and then you got the Mighty
Morphin Power Rangers movie you're like
wow it's like from the show but better
looking yeah yeah they had money for
actual film grades or film stocks and
things and yes real big sets but yeah
well for their visual Powers as well you
know for Monica's powers and then also
especially for kamala's Powers I feel
like when we see that on the big screen
that's gonna look even cooler when
you're comparing it to a television show
but as it stands you know for a trailer
I thought that was fine I think it's
still a weird time for the trailer to be
coming out when secret invasion is still
currently airing you know so man there
might lend some Credence to the theory
that the Nick fear that we're watching
here might be a scroll sure who knows uh
but I still think it's a little bit odd
that they would release this before
secret invasion is done which kind of
seems to undermine some of the stakes in
some degree when I'm like well I feel
like that chapter is going to be fine
now I feel like you would want to put
this out right after your finale or
something like that or something to to
give people that extra reminder that yes
these are connected but also yes not to
undercut what's happening with secret
Invasion yeah well outside of that
though uh I do feel like we're gonna get
a better vision of you know Brie
Larson's Charisma yes I felt like that
was something that was absent in the
first one because I think she is a great
actress if you watch interviews with her
I think she's actually a really Charming
actress despite what half the internet
seems to think about her I actually find
her to be a very Charming personality
and I really feel like that's present
here and to give her like the the other
actors to be able to bounce off of and
that was something that I'm hoping the
movie is really going to deliver on is
the kind of interplay between the three
of them like if we're talking about
secret Invasion one of the things I'm
loving about the show is just the scene
work right and then if you got three
great actresses sharing the screen
together I'm really excited to see how
they interact with one another
especially because you have you know
kamala's of reverence that she feels
towards you know Captain Marvel then you
got Monica with her childhood history
it's her auntie right there yeah yeah
yeah that her caribence is that she's
also feeling that she has to overcome
that we're hinted at in Wanda Vision I
think there's just a lot of great
character work that we could also get
here and right now they're still leaning
towards just a fun popping visuals when
I like the Beastie Boys song and it's
very apt uh for particularly this movie
I'm still not really getting quite as
good like the plot doesn't seem crazy
enough or intense enough or anything
like high stakes caliber enough to me to
currently you know like maybe it's more
quirky than like Earth bending or World
shattering necessarily and maybe it just
wants to be just fun but they got Nia
DeCosta here who I feel needed Costa can
bring like a Punch Yeah and dramatic you
know heft yeah while I like a lot of the
way the the visuals are looking for the
most part and while I like a lot of the
um the interchanging when they are
switching between sets and powers and
all that I think that all looks really
cool and maybe this will lead more into
something with the Multiverse perhaps
this can lead to some incursions I
really don't know exactly where it's
gonna go right now I'm like yeah I mean
this looks this looks fine this looks
like really this is entertaining uh it
doesn't look exceptional to me just yet
but maybe that's just enough for people
to be like I just want to walk out and
just have a really fun time and at the
end of the day I feel like that's all
I'm really gonna ask for is I just want
to have a fun time uh but when you're
telling me about these three characters
here finally crossing over and then you
need to Costa I feel like it has the
potential to be great yeah like a big
punctuation statement and I mean one
thing I do I am heartened by is the fact
that all the characters here look except
for Kamala Khan because she is so new
they're all more comfortable in their
lot and in what they're doing what their
mission is and like Nick Fury way more
laid back than when he and Carol first
met so like I feel like there's a lot of
potential for that kind of like better
more engaging personal drama but yeah I
don't know if this movie is aiming to be
like Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania
trying to be like a huge chapter you
know essential to this or if it just is
focused on trying to be the Captain
Marvel movie that people will really
meet and receive and sometimes I get
that that's not always about shooting to
the highest Stakes it's about shooting
to some more middle personal Stakes that
are maybe hard to pitch in like a
blockbuster trailer but yeah like at the
same time because so many powerhouses
are combining I get why you would want
this to feel like a momentous kind of
punctuation occasion yeah yeah but as it
stands guys I mean we're of course gonna
see this you know opening night or
earlier if we're fortunate enough to so
yeah we'll definitely be there and we'll
definitely be providing you out of the
theater review like we do so ladies and
gentlemen what did you think about the
trailer though leave your thoughts down
below please go ahead leave a like on
this video be sure to subscribe do all
those fun things and also if you are
going to be at Comic-Con please stop by
and lastly add a soda shirt only
available for a little bit of time so
please go ahead if you are interested in
getting one get one now talk with you
guys soon
[Music]